hi everyone and welcome to the third
q a since i've been back in 2020 and
the questions for this were submitted on
thinkspot
one week in advance of its recording the
video will also be published one week in
advance or a few days in advance on
thinkspot so if you'd like to be in on
it first you can
try it out there all right
so away we go with the questions
first why is the feminine
represented as chaos my feminist friends
often question that part of your
teaching
what is the archetypal role of women who
do not feel inclined
toward traditional modes of being well
we could answer the first question first
there is no archetypal role of women
or not a simple archetypal role of women
who do not feel inclined toward
traditional modes of being because
the archetype is the tradition so
that's a contradiction in terms
essentially
why is the feminine represented as chaos
well let's throw something back at your
feminist friends why
is the masculine represented as order by
feminists
i mean let's address that question
initially
so it seems to be an uh
a foregone conclusion that
the patriarchy is represented with
masculine symbols
and it seems equally a foregone
conclusion that
the patriarchy is order
so if the masculine symbolism is used by
feminists themselves to represent order
what is left for the feminine to be
represented by
order well that's already taken
and the reason your feminist friends
object to it is well i would say
fundamentally there's two reasons is
they object to everything and
they don't understand it and they don't
notice their own behavior
so why don't you ask them well why is
the masculine represented as order
and then there's a deeper answer too
which is well
in some sense i don't know it's not
me that's doing the representing
mean let's look at taoist symbolism
the taoists whose ideas i am definitely
not responsible for
who represent an age-old tradition
represent yin and yang as the two
fundamental modes of being in the famous
paisley dual paisley symbol it's
actually dual serpents head to head
um yin is feminine and yang is masculine
well why don't you get your feminists to
ask the taoists why
yin is feminine
now the reason is as far as i can tell
is that
the feminine challenges the masculine
and it challenges the masculine by
throwing the masculine into disorder
and it does that primarily through
rejection
and so if you're a man and you're trying
to embody productive order let's say
and you make an advance on a woman the
feminine you make an advance on the
feminine then we'll say archetypally
and you're rejected then that interjects
a tremendous amount of chaos into your
existence the chaos that's attended on
such a fundamental rejection
and that rejection may
require a total rethinking of the order
because the fundamental purpose of the
order at least as it's
manifested by men
the met the the masculine is to
be attractive to the feminine and so if
that's not working then
the order needs to be restructured and
then we might say well
ask your feminists this are they calling
constantly for the masculine to be
reordered
and obviously the answer to that is yes
except insofar as they also wish to
participate in it which is something
perhaps we'll get to later
they're always calling for the masculine
to be reordered
and so how would you symbolize what it
is that calls for order to be reordered
if you wouldn't symbolize it as
chaos so
you know i guess i'm somewhat annoyed by
this
by the by all appearances i guess it's
because
it isn't me doing this symbolic labeling
which is another thing that my critics
don't seem to understand
i didn't invent these symbolic domains
far from it
i'm merely drawing people's attention to
them
um you know and you might say well
what's the evidence that
the feminine is represented by chaos
well i outlined all sorts of evidence in
my three books
and carl jung has outlined all sorts of
evidence in his
you know 50 books and joseph campbell
has outlined all sorts of evidence and
eric neumann in the great mother which
is an absolutely superb book which you
could recommend to your feminist friends
certainly camille paglia would recommend
eric neumann's work because she's a
great fan of his so
he wrote a great book called the origins
and history of consciousness
which is one of the greatest books in
the union pantheon but
one that stands on its own and also one
that jung said he wished he would have
written
in in the forward to it so that's really
saying something and
then the great mother which is also by
eric neumann is a catalog
of the symbolism of the feminine which
you could
um encourage your feminist readers to
your feminist friends to read if they
would actually like to read something
that isn't within their pantheon let's
say but would add something
incredibly extraordinary and credible to
it
i mean palia believed that
neumann's viewpoint was the proper
path that literary criticism
and and by implication cultural
criticism
should have taken in the 20 late 20th
and 20 and early 21st century that's the
path i took
that's the path she took at least in
part
it's certainly not the path that the
universities took because they took the
path that is predicated on the
proposition that
our culture the west western culture
let's say
is predicated on the on power on the
arbitrary expression of power as the
fundamental human motivation
which is an unbelievably shallow and
uh erroneous conclusion
if the masculine is represented as order
even by feminists themselves
and if feminists are calling for a
complete complete
revamping of the patriarchal structure
then how in the world can those same
feminists
complain let's say when i
point out that the feminine is
symbolized by chaos
well in their case it's certainly acting
as chaos
and the other thing i should also insist
upon is that
i don't draw a moral distinction
with regards to the utility of order
versus chaos
order is the domain of what we have
comprehended and control
and we certainly want to comprehend
things and control them because we want
things to turn out the way we want them
to turn out and that's the definition of
control
but chaos is the domain
that surrounds that from which all new
things flow
which is also part of the reason that
it's feminine because the feminine is
that from which all
new things flow as well as that which
rejects the order and selects
these are very deep
issues they're very fundamental issues
i mean do your feminist friends also
doubt the reality of hypergamy
because that's the proclivity of women
to mate at
or up or across or up
hierarchies of socioeconomic status
it's been well documented across many
many cultures although it is ameliorated
to some degree
in the most egalitarian cultures as
opposed to being exaggerated
as personality traits are and those the
difference between men and women
personality is exaggerated in those
cultures
hypergamy is also an indication of the
feminine's tendency to reject the
current
embodiment of order in the form of the
masculine
entities that present themselves to her
let's say
so i don't think your feminist friends
have a leg to stand on with regards to
the criticism i just think they
want to have their cake and eat it too
and they haven't read the relevant books
and
they like to say things they haven't
thought through and they want
and and it's an easy way of dismissing
my ideas and they don't know what
they're throwing away when they throw
away the feminine identification with
chaos and plenitude and generation and
creativity and all of that because
somehow they think it's an insult
because they don't understand anything
about what i'm saying
and don't want to and so that's
that's the answer to your feminist
friends
do you think the underlying reason for
cancel culture is that we are so
connected through technology
but so isolated just wanting to be heard
what do you think is the deepest reason
well i don't think that the underlying
reason is
for cancer culture is that we are so
connected through technology
i think it would be happening anyways
i think it's possible that technology
facilitates
the kind of bullying that cancel culture
essentially represents by making it
somewhat easier and also
making it less likely that the people
who are doing it are going to be held
responsible for their actions
but i don't think it's the fact that
we're connected through technology and
i'm
presuming the questioner means modern
technologies
such as those that underlie the use of
social media rather than
you know books and and and
print and and tv and all those
technologies that we've had for
at least some time um the deepest reason
for cancel culture well i would say
there's two
deep reasons one is it's a form of
bullying
and it might even be a female specific
form of bullying or female
not specific that's wrong
it's the form of bullying that goes
after reputations essentially and that's
a feminine form of bullying
because the feminine use of aggression
tends to be reputation destruction and
cancer culture is a manifestation of
that and
i don't know to what degree cancel
culture and its assorted manifestations
are a manifestation of the feminine
tendency to
destroy reputations but it looks like it
looks to me like there's something to
that
so we don't know right we don't know how
female anti-social behavior
proclivities are going to manifest
themselves in the political realm but
would be foolish to think that they
won't because
they certainly manifested themselves in
you know male antisocial tendencies
certainly manifested themselves
in the male political realm so why would
we expect anything different on the
female side
in any case no i think the reason that
council culture exists is
well that there's this bullying issue
but there's an another deep
reason which is that the philosophy upon
which cancer culture rests
is the philosophy that states that the
fundamental
motivating drive and the organizing
principle
of western culture
is power and power is something like
the ability to use force to compel
others to act against their own
best interests or to act against what
they would freely choose
so it's the antithesis of informed
negotiation
right if i have power over you that
means i can force you to do my will
rather than negotiate with you to do our
will or to
allow you or to facilitate you
using your will so that's how i'm going
to use power in this discussion and
this culture war we're in is
fought against the philosophy that
presumes that it's power of that sort
that structures our social relations now
if you believe that
and you shouldn't because it's nonsense
it's
it's the anti-truth because that isn't
what structures our social relations
it's an aberration
upon what structures our social
relations well then you believe that
people individuals are nothing but the
mouthpiece of their group
and their their group identity
is beneficial to them because it allows
for their expression the expression of
their power and for the maintenance of
their status
and all of that if you believe that then
there's no dialogue between people
there's only power struggle
between groups and so you don't give
someone who isn't in your group the
opportunity to speak
or to exist for that matter why would
you because
they're just doing their power thing and
you're doing your power thing and it's
it's a battle of all against all and you
want your
power identity to win
so cancel culture is the logical outcome
of that reasoning
why would you you don't engage with your
opponents because there's no
you to engage there's no individual
there's just the group identity
expressed in power
so you can't have a rational discussion
modify your axioms and come to a
negotiated settlement that
that's all part of the enlightenment
hypocrisy or even deeper than that the
judeo-christian
hypocrisy now i take umbrage
to that let's say because i don't
believe that these principles
are even western in their derivation i
believe they're human universal
in their derivation and so unless
the people who are criticizing western
culture want to attribute to western
culture
only the best of human culture because
that's what this
is which i think is something they would
have a hard time swallowing
um i don't believe the best in human
culture has manifested itself as
the drive to power i think that's an
appalling philosophy
i think the only people who believe that
are those who use power to negotiate
their own social relations and who wish
they had the power
to negotiate the broader social contract
so i think the
hypothesis that power is the fundamental
motivation
is an unconscious confession on the part
of its professors
and i think all of their actions
indicate precisely that
so you know who you're dealing with when
you hear someone who makes that claim
they're either deeply cynical or they're
narcissistic or they're
machiavellian or and and they believe
that's how everyone else is
i think that comes i think that's
absolutely clear
for example in the writings of darada
who is
personally appalling as a human being in
every possible way
and i mean i think it is reasonable
under most conditions to separate the
thinker from his thoughts or her
thoughts but
i'd be willing to make an exception in
the case of darada
but he believed that power structures
human relations
that's where he got his sexual
gratification was through the expression
of power
and i believe he did think that that's
what structured human social relations
and that's how he acted and that's how
he thought
and so his effect as the most cited
social scientist ever
is so pernicious that it's it's it's
absolutely beyond comprehension
so so those are the reasons for cancel
culture it gives
malevolent machiavellians the
the uh opportunity to
bully in a manner that destroys
reputations without repercussion and so
there's no shortage of fun in that
and it gives those and it's required
ideologically for the sake of
consistency by those who claim
that power is the fundamental
structuring motivation of
western culture or perhaps culture at
large
insofar as it isn't possible to
distinguish between culture and western
culture
unless as i said you're willing to
attribute all the positive aspects of
human universal culture to
the west so the critique is broader than
a critique of western culture that this
is the point that i'm making it's a
critique of the fundamental human
endeavor the
golden thread that stretches back
centuries
and when they when the cultural critics
say
that this is a war of fundamentals they
mean that
this is a war that goes all the way to
the bottom it's a war about whether or
not
it's the logos that's the center of
motivation for human social structures
and their answer would be no it's the
power
mad adversary so
you can you can draw from that statement
whatever conclusion you want
it often seems like intelligent people
lack social skills where socially highly
competent persons are usually not all
that smart
no that isn't how it is
there are exceptions and much is made of
them i suppose
the popularity of the show the big bang
theory
is an indication of that so intelligence
gets caricatured
as um system
as the systematizing tendency versus the
empathizing tendency you can look that
up if you want this
the systematic the systemizing tendency
which is seen in its extreme in the case
of autism
is a part of the tendency to think
systematically and to prefer
things to people and there are
intelligent people who are systematizers
they're usually characterized as
nerds just and the most accurate
caricaturization
the most accurate caricature is
perhaps the big bang
or the most what would you say the most
amusing
caricature the most uh thoughtful
caricature but its popularity indicates
that
you know the trope has some merit some
identifiable merit
there are a subset of highly intelligent
people who are
systematizers and they tend to lack
social skills but even systematizers who
aren't intelligent lack social skills
and you can be virtually certain that
the more intelligent
systematizers have more social skills
than the less intelligent
systematizers so overall there's a
positive relationship between
intelligence and social skill make no
mistake about it because
intelligence is that's general cognitive
ability is such a pervasive phenomena
that ever
virtually everything that has a
cognitive element well i would say
everything that has a cognitive element
is positively correlated with iq or with
general cognitive ability
general iq is general cognitive ability
standardized and corrected for age by
the way
and general cognitive ability is the
proclivity
for people who do well on solving one
set of
abstract problems to solve all sets of
abstract problems
it's a unitary phenomena very powerful
unitary phenomena
phenomenon
[Music]
so it's just not the case and it's
certainly not the case that
emotional intelligence which doesn't
exist by the way
it's a manifestation of agreeableness on
the big five scale because the big five
does exist even though its
constituent elements don't have the same
predictive power as general cognitive
ability
they're reliably measurable and valid
predictors of many
uh non-obvious phenomenon
let's say so the big five extroversion
neuroticism agreeableness
conscientiousness
and openness were derived through
statistical techniques that are very
similar to those that were used to
derive
the single factor of general cognitive
ability sometimes parsed into verbal and
non-verbal intelligence and there's some
utility in that even though those two
are very highly correlated especially
across time
factor analysis which is the statistical
technique
applied to personality adjectives
reliably reveals that there are five
factors
and if you're talking about personality
you're talking about one or more of
those five factors whether you know it
or not and whether you want to or not
and that's
that now you could argue that there are
six factors the people who push the
hexaco model do argue that and
more power to them they seem to have
identified something useful in honesty
humility
perhaps maybe that's the inverse of what
the investigators into the dark triad
which includes machiavellianism
have also identified
there does seem to be a paucity of words
representing malevolence in the big five
and that's because those
judgmental words were parsed out of many
of the adjective lists
that were used to derive the big five to
begin with
there was an attempt to include
non-judgmental adjectives
in the initial derivation um
so maybe there are six factors but
there's certainly five and perhaps those
can be broken down into ten
we broke them down into ten my colin de
young
and i and some other compatriots
colleagues and students of mine
broke the big five down into ten aspects
if you're interested in that you can
use my personality test at
understandmyself.com
which also by the way enables you to
generate a couple's
report so if you and your partner
both do the personality test you can get
a couple's report that will identify
where you are simpatico let's say and
where you're likely to have trouble and
why
so you know hypothetically that's going
to be useful
and it's you know it is really useful to
know that some of the conflicts that
you're going to have with your partner
are a consequence of the differences
between your innate temperaments and to
know that those temperamental
differences exist
and to be able to take them into account
so
anyways it isn't the case that highly
intelligent people lack social skills
it is the case that we're very motivated
to look
at the deficits of highly intelligent
people because it's so annoying that
they exist
you know look when i taught at harvard i
used to have
some of the undergraduates over for
lunch or dinner not nearly as often as i
would have liked to or should have my
experience with the harvard
undergraduates was
that and they're very highly selected on
the basis of general cognitive ability
by the way although that's not the only
means of selection
even though it perhaps should be because
that would be more
fair than what's being done currently um
that doesn't say that that isn't to say
that that would be optimal because
conscientiousness might be taken into
account validly and so might openness
which is the creativity dimension
um if you're going to consider
personality
conscientiousness would be at the top of
the list
anyhow my observation with the harvard
undergraduates was one-third of them
were as smart as anybody
ever going to meet and those were people
kids
who you could teach something to and
they would immediately grip it and then
they would immediately generalize it
to areas that perhaps you haven't even
considered which is a hallmark of
extreme intelligence and also to some
degree of creativity
so that was always very interesting a
third of them would catch on
faster than virtually everybody who ever
met but didn't have that generalization
capacity and then a third would get it
if they worked
and so that was the harvard
undergraduate population and so i would
invite
students particularly from that upper
third let's say to
have lunch because they were very
interesting to me those kids
and get to know them and like they were
almost without exception and perhaps
without exception they were great people
you know they were
generally attractive they were socially
skilled they were
humble you know and going to an ivy
league school like harvard at least at
that time was a humbling experience
because no matter how smart you were
where you came from and you were very
likely to be a valedictorian for example
if you were admitted to harvard you were
not as smart as the p
as some of the people around you and you
were way not as smart as some of them
and so it was a humbling experience for
everyone now they might have been
puffed up because they were at harvard
to some degree but within harvard that
was a whole different story
that's not a place that's all that easy
on your ego as a first year
so uh you know and that's something to
think about if you barely got in
i would recommend if you barely got in
that you attend somewhere where you're a
bigger fish in a smaller pond
it'd be a lot easier on you
psychologically you know maybe the
connection network wouldn't be as good
but i would generally recommend that
you know you don't go somewhere where
you barely made it
i i don't think that's the best possible
route
anyways these kids at the
in the upper third of the upper you know
one tenth of one percentile
by no means lacked social skills
you know most of them were good athletes
because that was also a criteria for
admission or
they had performed some other quite
remarkable feat of
accomplishment at least one by the time
they were
applying because to get into harvard you
needed to have
extremely high general cognitive ability
let's say
you probably also needed to be
conscientious at least implicitly
but you definitely needed to have
accomplished
one or two remarkable things in your
life
before you got selected because general
cognitive ability wasn't enough because
harvard had a plethora of
candidates in the stratosphere
echelons of general cognitive ability
and so
you know i used to joke with my wife
after
we had a dinner like this that you know
we're both primed to want to hate this
highly accomplished person who had done
so much by the time they were 18 but
you know on meeting them you could see
exactly why they
got to where they were and that was
merit
insofar as that was properly selected
for by
the selection committee which at that
time was less corrupt than it is now
although not without its corruptions
so no wrong
intelligent people don't lack social
skills a subset of highly intelligent
people
who are systematizers in their thinking
lack social skills
and it's convenient for all the rest of
us insofar as we aren't in those upper
echelons of
general cognitive ability to look for
the weaknesses of those who are but
i'm afraid the story isn't that
comforting so
eq is not inversely proportional to iq
quite the contrary so
you know look think about it
the more complicated the cognitive
activity
the better at it people who have high
general cognitive ability are
now there isn't anything more
complicated than reading other people
so why would iq falter
in its prediction of that capability and
then let's think about this a little bit
further
with regards to convenience so let's say
you're a lawyer
or a clinical psychologist or a doctor
for that matter
and let's say that you've been selected
for
for that occupation well what's been
used to select you
well in the case of clinical
psychologist which is probably the most
relevant case although
lawyers and doctors also deal with
people all the time
and need to have a certain degree of
emotional intelligence which by the way
doesn't exist it's agreeableness
fundamentally in the big five pantheon
i think i forgot to finish that thought
earlier
in any case clinical psychologists are
selected
in large part although not entirely well
on the basis of their
gre scores that's the test used to get
into
to screen p applicants across
universities
when they apply to postgraduate clinical
psychology programs which are very very
very hard to get into so which means
that the applicant to
admission ratio is extremely high
it's at least as hard to get into as
medical school and i would argue
probably harder but i might be wrong
because they're both very hard to get
into
um they're you're basically selected on
the basis of your gre scores
about a third of your application would
be
a concept of your success would be a
consequence of your gre scores
and your grades and both of those are
central markers for general cognitive
ability and so
all the people who publi practice
clinical psychology have been selected
on the basis of general cognitive
ability and maybe that's not the only
criteria that should have been used and
it isn't because
you know evaluation committees look at
things like letters of recommendation
which are
not particularly valid predictors of
competence by the way but
maybe can be used to screen out you know
by reading between the lines generally
the letters of recommendation for
anybody applying to programs that are
highly selective are glowing and so it's
very difficult to differentiate between
them and
a predictor with no differentiation has
no utility
and increasingly people are loath to
provide accurate
letters of recommendation because
they're afraid that
well they'll be caught up in some
scandal if they let their opinion be
known so they're
in all likelihood becoming less valid
predictors
but in any case i'm hammering this point
home because it needs to be hammered
home
intelligent people are better at
everything that's complicated
it's the nature of intelligence it's the
central nature of intelligence
and you know there are vast differences
in intelligence between people and those
have
massive real world consequences and
doesn't that just
suck well it certainly does it's
perhaps the most inedible object that
psychological research has
you know generated for your delectation
and it isn't even clear that our culture
can absorb the knowledge without
crumbling
so but there it is and and we're forced
to deal with it now the upside is
because we can measure
general cognitive ability and this
you've got to think this through people
everyone we can sort people on general
cognitive ability
and so that's a bloody catastrophe for
those who don't make the sorting isn't
it
and something has to be done about that
and some thought put into it
some real thought put into it not hand
waving that says
everyone can be trained to do anything
which is liberal
it's a lie it's not true
it's an anti-truth unfortunately because
wouldn't it be lovely if that was the
case
you know and hard work which is
expressed in trait conscientiousness
can compensate to some degree
but no matter how hard i work for
example i'm never going to be the kind
of
mathematician that can do cosmological
level or
or particle level physics i've seen
mathematical geniuses i've had some of
them as students
they could learn in a month what took me
five years not to learn
very well i had a student who was a
systematizer on the autistic
spectrum and although also highly
verbally proficient
in in her systematic way god she learned
more about statistics in two months
being my graduate student than i did in
12 years of being a
phd candidate and then a researcher and
and
you know she won awards for teaching
statistic
statistics in her first semester
and those concepts to her were like
reading an abc book for me
and i'm not like that you know i have
some sense of my own intellectual
limitations i certainly see them in the
mathematical realm
my verbal intelligence is very high but
my non-verbal intelligence
is it's high but it's not very high and
i've met people who have very high
non-verbal intelligence and had the
privilege to work with them
but you know the thing about the sorting
is that it's well obviously it's
extremely hard on people who
don't make the cut in in whatever
direction the cut is being made but
it allows the rest of us morons to
be in a position to take preferential
advantage of the talent that we've
winnowed and that is now being
presented to us and so we have to ask
ourselves what's in our best
interest people are we going to swallow
the bitter pill
of differences in general cognitive
ability so that we can exploit for our
own utility
the massive advantage that those who
have high general cognitive ability are
able to present to us
and are we going to play the game
straight so that we do open the door
to those who have proficiency in that
regard so they can maximize their talent
and
and therefore benefit the rest of us
because that's what we do when we use
objective
merit-based screening for application to
places like harvard
and if we did that well we'd stop
screening out the asians
for example which is an unbelievably
perverse thing to do given that they
have an edge
in conscientiousness probably for
cultural reasons
but it's certainly the case that at ivy
league institutes
very very many asians in particular
who have exceptional general cognitive
ability are being screened out of the
competition
for personality defects and it's it's
appalling and you know if the liberals
who are listening to this and there's
probably not that many of them but
for the liberals who are listening to
this is that really the kind of
diversity that you're promoting
is that what you want you're going to
hobble
the ability of the entire culture to
take advantage
of the pool of human intelligence that
our testing
uh technology allows us to identify
now you know those people who are
screened out and go to lesser
less prestigious institutions than
harvard are likely to do pretty damn
well there
as well so you know there are people who
are going to land on their feet but
that's not the point the point is
our most prestigious institutes should
be most open to those who are most
capable of most
benefiting and though it's clearly those
who would be selected with objective
objective analysis and for those of you
who object to the idea of objective
analysis
you just try and replace it with
something better
something better you know extremely
highly trained and extraordinarily
intelligent
psychometric experts have been trying to
do that for
a hundred years supported by the best
research institutions in the world
and they have come up with general
cognitive ability and conscientiousness
and that's a really hard game to beat i
tried
developing a neuropsychological battery
as an adjunct to
general cognitive ability for example
and did actually manage to differentiate
the personality screeners in some useful
manner by breaking them into the 10
aspects that are
tested again in the myo in
understandmyself.com
and we found some incremental predictive
utility in that differentiation
that took 15 years of research effort
which
involved by the way some of those people
who were selected for
extraordinarily high general cognitive
ability um
on the basis of the test that i was
trying to compete with my my competition
wasn't successful except insofar as i
was able to differentiate
with my colleagues able to differentiate
uh
personality you know into ten aspects so
that meant we broke conscientious down
in
conscientiousness down into
industriousness and orderliness
and industriousness seems to be a better
predictor of
performance in social institutions than
does orderliness
there's some domain-specific prediction
that that still remains for orderliness
but
you know so but that that was a small
incremental utility improvement
you're not going to replace general
cognitive ability with anything that's
better
and hey man knock yourself out trying i
did for 15 years
i built a commercially applicable
product as well
which i couldn't sell because it was too
accurate and therefore too threatening
and that brings us to the next question
what are your thoughts on the
myers-brigg personality type indicator
as opposed to the big five
well myers-briggs was not generated
with modern statistical technology and
has all the lacks you'd expect so
the it was generated as a consequence of
its purported um
affinity for or identity with jung's
theories although
it's not a product that carl jung either
used or produced or as far as i know
approved of not to say that he outright
disapproved of it but
it's not a direct consequence of his
work
on his domain it's an it's a consequence
of inferences about his work from
other people who studied his content and
generally that doesn't go that well
with the possible exception of eric
neumann for example and
a few others who i've put on my reading
list which
of recommended books which you can
access at jordanbpeterson.com
under books under recommended books now
the myers-briggs is widely used as a
personality
test why well there's
there's some things to be said in its
favor it does provide a relatively
accurate
index of extroversion for example it
lacks neuroticism entirely which is a
big
problem um and the terminology it uses
is best replaced
and i'm saying this you know despite my
admiration for jung's thought
it's best replaced with the factor
analytically derived
terms that are used in the big five and
in the
big ten aspect scale
so it should be supplanted by those
tests validly
to serve the purposes of valid
prediction and reliable testing
now why is the myers-briggs so popular
well i think the reason it's so
there's two reasons that and they're
valid reasons the first is that it is
important for people to understand that
people differ
on the basis of their temperament that a
systematizer for example who would be
low in agreeableness
um and and generally low in neuroticism
but low in agreeableness certainly a
systematizer does differ from an
empathizer who would be high in
agreeableness
um that there are is
diversity in the way that people process
the world
and that considering that diversity is
actually useful if you actually consider
the diversity which is to be found far
more in the realm of personality than it
is in the realm of
inalienable attributes there's
no reliable data as far as i know
on racial differences in personality
so the diff the diversity that the
diversity
inclusivity and equity people are
striving to
include is actually to be found in the
domain of personality and not where
they're looking
um and the evidence for that is crystal
clear
so and is it useful to
have a diverse range of personalities in
your
um organization and
well that's a complicated question
because it's
preferentially useful to have a very
large
number of conscientious people in your
workforce
because they get the job done now you
know conscientious people do tend to be
a bit more conservative because they're
they also tend to be orderly and so they
might not be as open to new ideas
as those who are not inhibited to such a
degree by orderliness
so it's the absence of an impediment
rather than the
presence of a feature but
we don't understand the relationship
between openness which is the creativity
dimension and
conscientiousness well enough to make
more differentiated
uh predictions so anyways is it useful
to have a diversity of
of personalities in your workforce well
in so far as having a diversity of
personalities in your workforce
enables you to understand the target
market which includes a diverse
range of personalities and in so far as
having a diverse range of personalities
has been useful for the general human
enterprise which is why it's been
selected for
it's possible that it's useful for your
organization but
but you know that's still somewhat
problematic claim given that
the evidence suggests that a
preponderance of conscientious people is
very helpful if you want to undertake
what it is that you plan to undertake
and then the open people might be
necessary for vision and
more emotionally stable people for
resilience and
more agreeable people to understand and
empathize with
everyone within the organization but
also with the general community
and disagreeable people who because
they'll tell you what they think and
work as you know whistleblowers by
bringing things that will produce
conflict to your attention because
they're not conflict diverse these are
very complicated matters
now what the myers-briggs personality
myers-briggs temperamental inventory
does
or personality type indicator does to
the dialogue is bring it up
fundamentally in a non-threatening way
so you can administer the myers-briggs
and while you're doing that you can
inform
everyone that temperamental differences
exist and that they matter and that
they're real
and you can get the dialogue going and
no one gets offended by their
myers-briggs personality type
categorization and
when i so i tried to market a
neuropsychological battery
um that involved the cognitive
operations of the prefrontal cortex
that's what it tested
as well as assessing conscientiousness i
tried to market that to corporations for
about 20 years and it was
except in one case a dismal failure and
the reason for that was
really i'm telling you the truth is that
it was too accurate and
so one of the things would happen is
that the manager that i was speaking to
would want to take the test and he would
generally score somewhere around the
50th percentile
which doesn't mean he got 50 percent on
the test
it meant that he did as well as the
average manager which is what you'd
expect the average manager to do
that meant he was better than one out of
two managers which is actually pretty
good
but he'd look at it and he'd think well
i'm 50th percent
you know i got 50 on this test
because he wasn't statistically versed i
got 50
on this test well it can't be accurate
because of course i'm a good manager
well
which being better than one and a half
managers makes you
um you know how can i rely on this to
select
people well maybe you want to select
people who are better than you are but
maybe you don't because that is
threatening and well and it is
a test that actually ranks people on the
basis of their
merit in relationship to a job
especially your job
is actually extremely threatening and
what we found
despite our repeated attempts was that
it was so
threatening that people were loath to
use the test
even though we could make a case for its
unbelievable economic advantage so it's
so advantageous to hire
better people than to not hire them then
there isn't a single decision that you
can make
in your company that's more important
than who you hire and the economic
utility of even small improvements in
your hiring process is
absolutely overwhelming and that can
also be demonstrated mathematically but
that means that the person you're
talking to
has to be able to understand and open to
mathematical arguments and
also by your story which they
won't aren't necessarily prone to do it
also means that the person you're
talking to
who's doing the selection has to benefit
directly
or at least not be punished for
improving the selection process and the
way that most corporations are set up
is that those who accrue benefit from in
from improving the hiring process are
not those who are in control of the
hiring process
so the incentives are lined up in a
perverse way
so for example many of the people that i
was negotiating with they would tell me
they couldn't pay for the test i'd say
well like
this test has a 500 to one return on
investment what do you mean you can't
pay for it's not like we were charging
an arm and a leg by the way either
well i get evaluated on the cost
side and the benefits get evaluated
on someone else's watch well you know
then i'm dead in the water aren't i
because i there's no argument that i can
make that will convince you to use the
test because
you'll be punished for its shortcomings
and someone else will be rewarded for
its benefits
end of story and and we never did market
this
product successfully despite you know 15
years of work
much of it published in the scientific
literature so anyways back to the
myers-briggs well
it's a non-confrontational way of
introducing discussion about personality
into the workforce and so
it's to be lauded for that and it does
provide people with some
information well it certainly provides
them with information that there are
differences in personality and that's a
useful
pedagogical um uh
contribution let's say so thumbs up to
the myers-briggs people for that
for making a uh test that people could
bear
using now the problem is is that it's
not the most accurate test
the most accurate test as far as i'm
concerned and you can
for those of you who are able you can
decide whether this is a valid claim or
not is the
understandmyself.com personality test
the big five
the ten aspect big five ten aspects
slash big five
markers and that paper by the way has
been cited
i'll just look at google scholar here
for a minute
the paper that that colin de young was a
student of mine at the time
wrote along with daniel higgins and
no along with lena quilty my my my
mistake daniel higgins is
my partner in the business and also a
co-author on
the next three most highly cited papers
that i've been associated with anyways
the paper is
between facets and domains 10 aspects of
the big five
and it's been cited 1700 times
um where the median citation it it's
been cited a lot it's the highest
citation count paper i have and 1700
citations is
a very large number of citations that
that would be a moderate career level
citation for a moderately successful
researcher rather than just the citation
count for one paper
so people do have some regard for the
ten aspect
theory and increasingly so um
that means they're more and more papers
published using it so if you really want
to know
what your personality is i would say use
understand myself and then you can also
understand your
your coupling better um
if you want a non-confrontational
introduction to the idea
that personality diversity exists
then use the myers-briggs but it isn't
going to give you
the most differentiated information that
you can have
so um i guess if i was pushed
though and i uh you know someone from a
corporation said to me well which one
would you recommend using in the
corporate environment
well i'd make two cases i'd say well if
you want to avoid conflict use the mbti
if you want to help people understand
their personalities and
use an accurate instrument to do so
for whatever cost that might have as
well then use the
10 aspect scale because it's the most
accurate and differentiated personality
measure that exists
as far as i'm concerned the hexaco model
is great
and a standard big five like the neo pir
is also these are these are good
instruments it's not like it's the only
one but i think it's
got the stats right at the most
fundamental level and it offers the most
differentiation
so it gives you the biggest accuracy
bang for your buck
if you're interested in accuracy and it
doesn't take very long you know it's a
hundred questions and
you can wrap them off pretty quickly and
and you get a lot of information about
who you are
uh that's useful as far as i'm concerned
okay next question how does one restore
trust in our political medical judicial
and other social systems when they're
proving out to be fraudulent with every
passing day
well look the first first thing is
they've been
proving out to be fraudulent to some
degree
every day throughout the entire span of
human history
this is not new it's an existential fact
it's a transcendental existential fact
and that's why there's an archetype of
the
tyrant and we've used the archetype of
the tyrant to represent
the entire patriarchy it's implicit in
that term
the culture war right now is about
whether or not the patriarchy is a
tyrant
it's a symbolic battle you know and the
chaotic feminine is coming
to to demand the restructuring
that's what's playing out in in our
culture but it's always playing out
that's why it's archetypal
that's why it's expressed in these deep
symbols it's not like i'm in favor of it
exactly it's
it's just as far as i can tell that's
how it is so
you're you're
you're asking how you restore trust in
our political medical judicial and other
social systems when they're proving out
to be fraudulent well first of all you
realize that
you're that doesn't make your position
unique
you've realized that well how fraudulent
are they that's the real issue
and compared to what are they more
fraudulent than you
i doubt it so that's a good place to
start
that's why you know
express my viewpoint that you start by
cleaning up your own
soul and maybe you start by with your
room which by the way you can look at my
room it's now clean
and i haven't just hidden the mess in
the corner so
not that it couldn't use some more
cleaning because it certainly could and
so could i
but you know really fraudulent
but what are you doing about it you know
being morally appalled
and and putting yourself on a moral
plane that in some sense supersedes
social institutions themselves so that's
your claim i'm a better human being
than the average social institution is
moral
really really you think that do you
think that you're a better human being
than the american court system
for example you know all things
considered
i understand it has its flaws
so i doubt that
so and then the next thing i would say
is
so they've been proving fraudulent
forever and mostly they're
not fraudulent okay so we got to keep
that in mind because
they're fraudulent compared to our
hypothetical ideal
but you have to be careful with that
because you know if you're going to go
around imposing
the hypothetical ideal as the proper
moral standard well then you have to
live
up to it and good luck with that but it
also gives you carte blanche to
you know abandon the system
because of its moral inadequacy and also
to claim that every action you take
which is in
service of this hypothetical higher good
is justified because the higher good is
so much higher
and so every iniquity on your part that
can be justified by your hypothetical
end is now permissible
and if you don't think the malevolent
part of you will take advantage of that
moral claim then you don't know anything
about malevolence
so now what can you do about it
how does when we store trust in our
medical political medical judicial and
other social systems
well i would say by acting as an
honorable
agent with integrity in all of your
dealings
starting with your relationship with
yourself extending to your relationship
with your intimate other
extending past that to your family
extending past that to your community
extending past that to the economic and
political systems that
you serve and that serve you and so if
you want to restore trust in
the system well then start by being
trustworthy
and that will help that's what you can
do and you know being trustworthy that's
no
mean feat right that that makes you
really something that makes you someone
who can be relied on to keep their
contractual obligations
it's a very powerful act don't don't
mistake it for
something trivial and local it's
to be a beacon on the hill is no is no
trivial accomplishment
so get at it and then the next thing i
would say is
well do you belong to a political party
have you ever
democratic republican i don't care have
you ever
contributed to the political medical
judicial and other social systems that
you're decrying
insofar as you're able i mean i've had
some experience working with political
parties when i was a kid
on later in life as well but you know i
had status by that
point but so we'll go back to when i was
a kid 14
i worked with the ndp a socialist party
in alberta
and the doors were open man believe me
these political parties they're
starving to death for for committed
individuals to help so if you're
concerned about
these fraudulent social systems it's
like hey
fix one it's right there in front of you
there isn't a
single political party in my country
there isn't a single political party in
my country that wouldn't welcome a young
person who wanted to contribute
to making it better with open arms and
great relief
and so and it's the same with the
judicial
medical and other systems it's like well
if you're concerned about fraudulence in
the medical profession you're really
concerned about it well then maybe
you should be a nurse or a doctor like
this is on you
it's not they and maybe you can you know
when you listen to people talk and
and they keep talking about the they
that's the problem
you got to ask yourself well are you
sure it's there or is it us
because for most of the time it's us and
so
you know how much are you proving to be
fraudulent with every passing day
that's the right question you know and a
couple of hundred thousand
non-fraudulent young people while
that have a major impact and so maybe
you could start by being one of them
so this standing back as a young
individual and criticizing the social
system it's
it's a fool's game it's like you're the
beneficiary and the victim
but you're all you know the beneficiary
as well as the victim
and if it's fraudulent well it's
fraudulent to the same degree
no it's less it's less fraudulent than
you you can be virtually
certain of that at least when the system
is functional
because it's functional and sometimes
highly functional
so
so you know allowing yourself to be
disenchanted by that
is just an excuse for not picking up
your responsibility and getting the hell
on with it
it's like the system's broken yeah it's
always been broken
the old man is blind yeah he's always
been blind
he speaks words of slogans yeah well
that's always been the case bloody
the the the ancient egyptians had this
figured out
you know the mesopotamians before them
had this figured out
it's not a news story the old dying king
is corrupt
yeah right no kidding that's why you
rescue him from the belly of the beast
that's your goal as a
job as an individual so get at it
and don't let your cynicism confuse you
into thinking that it's wisdom it might
be wisdom compared to naive optimism but
it's not true wisdom true wisdom is
you're the problem
and then fix it and if you want more
reliable social institutions well start
by becoming more reliable and then
start working for the social
institutions
so you might say well they're so
fraudulent and corrupt that we need to
replace them it's like yeah
then i think we just maybe not allow you
the opportunity to do that
you know because really you that's what
you're going to do and that's going to
work out well
what else has worked out well in your
life oh radical one
that segues into this question quite
nicely
i've come to harbor some pessimistic
beliefs about human nature
i'm young and optimistic about my future
but i've grown disenchanted by how i see
each other's see others treat each other
how do you believe we can bring back
optimism in human relationships
um well of course you're going to be
disenchanted because you were young and
naive and so
being disenchanted is part of maturing
but the next part of maturing is to move
forward optimistically
as an axiom of your faith in mankind and
yourself
as a recognition of your moral
obligation to do so
right so now your eyes are open you see
well you know
there's a snake in the garden and kane
is your brother
well yeah it's always been that way and
welcome to reality
so what do you do you allow that to make
you corrupt and nihilistic
not if you think that it's the
corruption and the nihilism that's the
problem
so you're obligated to be optimistic in
some sense
despite the evidence and that's
faith so you know pick up your cross and
stumble uphill
consciously
and you bring back optimism in human
relations by structuring your own
to the best of your possible ability
and that'll expand outward as you become
more competent move through your life
be productive generous
kind discerning wise
educated you be a good father
to everyone not the tyrant
that resentment breeds in your own heart
and that's an act of moral courage
and that's real maturity
so and and if you want an adventure well
there's one for you
i have low intelligence and feel
hopeless what jobs do you recommend
i take
well you're probably not particularly
well suited for jobs that require a
tremendous amount of
transformation of thinking or a
tremendous amount of abstraction
but that doesn't mean there are no jobs
for you
and so jobs that are more stable and
repetitive
routine let's say you're better suited
for
vocational jobs and there's
vocational jobs playing a
remarkably important role in our culture
so and hard work can get you a long ways
and so you know i don't know what you
mean when you say low intelligence
you know i mean there are
catastrophically low intelligence
ratings say 60 and below
it's tough to find anything that you're
going to be able to be productive
in doing and i don't know what to do
about that
above that hard work is going to make a
huge difference
and aiming right so
aim at the vocational end of the
distribution and put a plan in place
and stick to it and work diligently at
it that's what you've got
you've got your ability to work and
maybe you can capitalize on your other
personality attributes as well and as
i've said already in this podcast you
can do a personality test at
understandmyself.com i would also say
on my selfauthoring.com website
there's an opportunity for you to map
out a plan
and this one of the to map out a plan to
write about your past but also to write
about your present self so
the present authoring program enables
you to
do an inventory of your personality
strengths and weaknesses and
there's a virtues analysis and a false
analysis and i would say if you're
leery about your future for whatever
reason you should do the virtues
analysis it's like what have you got to
offer
and hopefully you have the ability to
work hard and maybe you have other
personality attributes that are
important
and that you could understand and then
capitalize on so i would say
do the understandmyself.com personality
test
do the virtues section of the present
authoring exercise at selfauthoring.com
put together a plan and aim at the
vocational end of the job distribution
don't despair there's plenty of
opportunity at that level
for someone who's honest which is a huge
advantage
who has integrity who's willing to work
hard
i'm not going to sugarcoat it you know
life is harder at the shallow end of the
gene pool let's say
to use scars phrase from the lion king
we're all at the shallow end of the gene
pool in some regard you know
so the cognitive end is that's a rough
hit
but general cognitive ability isn't
everything
even though it's a lot of things and so
aim integrity hard work
a plan that's what you've got
and so you have to make the best of it
how can i tell if i'm being authentic or
possessed by an idea
in the past things i thought were me
were just cultural fads
another question allied with that how
can i tell if i'm being truthful in the
present if i can only look reflexively
at an outcome
to see if it was fit enough from a
pragmatic perspective
that's a complicated question we'll
start with the first one how can i tell
if i'm being authentic or possessed by
an idea
look when you were possessed by those
ideas you might have been at least
partially authentic because one of the
things you might ask yourself
is well were they stepping stones to a
better you
you know people get possessed all the
time because they admire certain ideas
and sometimes that admiration
impels them into a kind of
apprenticeship and so they were stupider
before they got possessed by that idea
and
as they transf
transformed themselves across the
apprenticeship cycle
say being apprenticed to this fad like
idea
they learn something from it so you know
you might
you might have learned and grown as a
consequence of what
possessed you now you know it's possible
that a lot of that spoke
to the development of parts of you that
you don't want to develop you know that
they spoke to your malevolence and spoke
to your desire to manipulate and all of
that
and you have to sort that out but
look i also don't think it's all that
easy to
figure out when you're authentic that
that's subtle
you know you you your felt sense of
confidence in your words when you're not
trying to win
is something like your ability to judge
your authenticity
you know are you saying this to achieve
a local end or are you saying this
because
you have thought deeply and this is the
best expression you can manage of a
deeply held
conviction that's a lifetime it's a
lifetime of work or it's a lifetime work
to sort those
things out the best i could come up with
was in
my first book well the first of the more
popular books
in 12 rules for life
don't lie now not lying is not the same
as being authentic exactly because
as your question highlights it's not
that easy to tell when you're telling
the truth
right because well what the hell do you
know it's certainly not the truth what
you know it might be your best
approximation but it's certainly not the
truth and
you're by no means unerring in your
ability to discern
when it is that you're even speaking
your truth because that's so complicated
you just have to practice doing that
continually to get
anywhere near good at it like so it's
years and years of effort to a
stringent moral effort to begin to
manage that
but i do believe that people can tell
by and large when they're outright lying
and they can stop doing that they can
stop saying things they know
to be false and so that's
the most obvious impediment to
authenticity is
outright lies of commission
stop engaging in those stop saying
things you know to be false now
that begs the question how do you know
them to be false well
that's complicated sometimes that's a
feeling of repugnance at your own words
sometimes it's a feeling of touchy
embarrassment so that if people call you
in what you say you get
disproportionately angry
um sometimes it's knowing a set of facts
that you haven't let
affect the way you think or present
yourself
you know you're purposefully keeping
yourself in the fog
as per rule three of beyond order
um those are all things you have to sort
out for yourself but i think it starts
with
an act of faith and which is at least in
part why religious systems insist upon
faith
and faith isn't belief in something that
no one's saying would believe you know
that's that's a misapprehension of faith
faith is something like a decision
that
truth serves the good and the good is
worth serving and
so therefore truth is worth serving it's
just that's an axiomatic proposition
and you can debate its empirical
justification
and of course we wouldn't be tempted
into temptation if we couldn't debate
its empirical
justification because the objection is
yeah and what exactly does truth buy you
that falsehood
wouldn't buy you better and if you don't
think that you're tempted by that
counter position well then you don't
know anything about temptation because
that
is the temptation of the counter
position so and it's powerful temptation
that's why it's a statement of faith
that this that
that um conquers it
it's a decision
so you probably were
possessed by an idea but maybe there was
something in you that was striving to be
authentic and
maybe you can speed that process of
transformation along by
vowing by taking a vow and that's
adopting a religious
commitment which is i'm going to serve
truth and the good despite
the proximal cost and that's a statement
of faith because you're
staking your life on that right because
every decision you make from here
on in will be a will be affected by that
by that decision so it's a fundamental
decision
and hopefully that will guide you
in your endeavor so that your possession
by cultural fads
which might be a necessary part of your
apprenticeship will be temporary and
serve
this zigzagging path to something that's
better for you
in the future
the second question how can i tell if
i'm being truthful in the present if i
can only look reflexively at well you
can't if you can only look reflexively
at an outcome to see if it was fit
enough
from a pragmatic perspective then you
can't
tell if you're being truthful in the
present virtually by definition
but i wouldn't say why do you think you
can only look reflexively at an outcome
to see if it was fit enough from a
pragmatic perspective
i don't think you're bound by that
exactly
now i know there's a deeper issue at
hand there because i've
claimed to be a pragmatist for example
or at least
to some degree
problem with this question is there's
really three questions in it and they
have to be answered at the same time
how can i tell if i'm being truthful in
the present or maybe there's five
questions
if i can only that's another question
because can you only look reflexively
that's another question at an outcome
that's another question
to see if it was fit enough from a
pragmatic perspective i would say that
there are too many
questions in that question for me to
unpack simultaneously
um so what i would encourage you to do
is to break your question down into some
questions and try again because i can't
answer all of them at once i don't have
the mental wherewithal to do it
i see what you're driving at
but it's just too much it's too many
questions packed into one to be able to
unpack
spontaneously so it has been wonderful
to see tammy in interviews lately would
you and her continue doing
consider doing a q a for young couples
who want to get married
and for those already married who want
to stay married would love to see you
together
two together all the best another top
question on thinkspot
well i think we would consider it i can
bring it up with her
um i and i will
and yes i guess we would consider it i
don't know if i'm in a state
and i don't know if she is either to do
that in the spontaneous way that it
would really need to be done
you know because that should be
something that's live but we could
consider
doing a q a like this on that
topic and so well look we'll see what
the comments section
says when this is released on youtube
and maybe we'll make our decision
as a partial consequence of that but
thank you for asking and
um i'm pleased that
you've been positively affected by
tami's appearances on
on youtube um the general response to
what
the general response to what she's been
saying has been overwhelmingly positive
and so of course that's
very reassuring for me because she put
herself out there and
for her as obviously as well so it would
be that it would be interesting to do
that with her so i'll bring it up with
her
you know we keep thinking we keep
thinking well who are we to
offer such advice you know and tammy is
doing everything she can to
hammer herself into the sort of person
who would be capable of doing that which
is i suppose what a grandmother should
be
so but it's not like we're both hyper
confident in our capacity to
to do such things i guess maybe we're
all that you
have got and so tough luck for us and
you
so but
you know but we struggle with that with
regard to sexuality you said that it is
a good question to ask yourself who is
in control
well yeah that's the question isn't it
you know if you're masturbating to
pornography and the consequence of that
is an immediate influx of guilt
then you have to ask yourself who's in
control
and that's a really important question
who's in control
that's what terrified me about
developing some psychoanalytic acumen
because once you realize that you're
a house that many spirits can and do
inhabit
and that many of them aren't you and
that many of them aren't working
towards the purposes you might want
yourself to be working to
and that's the realization of the myth
that you're embodying
from the union perspective it's a very
very serious question
the fundamental human myth is cain
versus abel
and so who are you are you kane or abel
well the answer is you're both
and then the question is well who's got
the upper hand
and then the next question is who do you
want to have the upper hand
is it god and abel or satan and cain
and that's a question that's just as
germane to non-believers as it is to
believers
and isn't that remarkable and appalling
and overwhelming and terrifying
all at the same time if you have any
sense of what it means
so if your behavior is embarrassing you
well there's only two possibilities
isn't there you shouldn't be so
embarrassed
and i suppose the voice that says
yes to all expression of human sexuality
would say that your
guilt and shame is merely the
detrimental hangover of an
oppressive patriarchy that's judgmental
in its attitudes towards sexuality
well yeah well what would you use
judgment to differentiate if it isn't
sexuality
so i don't think that argument goes
anywhere you have to consult your own
conscience like i know
the conscience can become an oppressive
force on its own that's the
indwelling of the great tyrant you know
and freud made much of that
a too oppressive superego and i've
certainly seen clients whose
expression of healthy sexuality was
inhibited by a too rigid superego that
can definitely happen
but that doesn't mean that all guilt
about all forms of sexual expression
constitutes a superego
run amok i mean it doesn't take a genius
to figure out that there was some
relationship between the sexual
revolution of the 1960s which
according to randy thornhill by the way
who's perhaps the world's top biology
biological thinker on this particular
topic thornhill believed that the
liberalism of the 60s was a consequence
at least in part
and in large part i should say of the
hygienic revolution
of the previous six decades and more
that enabled us to reduce the
impact at least in the west of
infectious diseases and because we were
much less prone to the transmission and
receipt of infectious diseases
we could afford to be more liberal by
the 1960s
so we got more sexually liberal and what
happened
aids and i say that without prejudice
and what's the most effective means of
facilitating the reproduction of a
deadly virulent agent and its
propagation through the population
unrestrained sexual behavior
and so that would be a multitude of
partners
so sexual shame is there for a reason
and it's not a trivial reason and it's
not just going to go away because we may
wave the magic wand and make the
patriarchal oppressor vanish
and that's not going to happen either by
the way
so if you're ashamed about your sexual
behavior then you have to ask yourself
is the shame wrong or is the sexual
behavior wrong and i'm asking you
i'm not judging your behavior because
what the hell do i know about you
and i have enough trouble with my own
behavior so
you know this is on you
is your shame what you should be
dispensing with or the
behavior and you know it might be a
little a column and a little column b
because life is never simple but if you
don't feel ennobled by your
porn related masturbation then perhaps
that means it's of questionable utility
i certainly don't see it as a
stabilizing social force
i don't see it as something people do in
public and and brag about
and and i know that sexual behavior is
private and should remain that way but
you get what i'm driving at so
look i think people shouldn't lie
especially to themselves
and i think repeatedly engaging in a
behavior that you
judge yourself to be morally
reprehensible is a form of performative
contradiction which is the
acting out of a lie and i suspect you
know that or you wouldn't be asking the
question
and so you know what should you do with
pornography
well you know the answer to that and so
does everybody else
everyone knows it's not good it's not
good for those who
produce it it's not good for those who
participate
withingly or unwittingly because there's
plenty of them
in its production it's not good for its
consumers
or certainly not the highest good and
what's the highest good
sexuality incorporated within a
functional
intimate relationship
bound by vows of mutual celibacy
and we all know that too
that stabilizes our families it
stabilizes our societies
it stabilizes our psyches and so
anything you do that isn't in service of
that goal is likely to be
counterproductive and
i suspect it's your own psyche your own
soul
telling you that so
if your sexuality if your sexual
behavior isn't an expression of your
highest being
then it it isn't serving you in the
deepest sense
you're serving it and that's what your
shame indicates
so get out there and find a partner
and commit to her or him
i feel like being forced to wear masks
is a violation of personal rights
but i want to respect the rights of
businesses to decide what they require
how do i act i feel weak as you say i
feel if i don't stop wearing them i'm
participating in a lie
and if i don't stop there's no end look
everybody is
torn apart by this situation and no one
really knows what to do
and that includes me you know um
i think all by and large the entire
human race has done a remarkable job of
dealing with this pandemic
that the cities are our cities are not
burning down our economies are not in
tatters we're not completely out of our
minds and
really that's quite an accomplishment
now are our cities partly in tatters
and are we partly insane yes definitely
and do we know that all of what we did
was good well it most certainly wasn't
but we stumbled by not too badly and you
know with any luck this is going to come
to an end so i guess my advice and this
is the advice i follow myself
is i think it's time to suspend judgment
for
six months sometimes you don't know what
to do
and you know your conscience is
bothering you because
well being forced to wear masks
obviously is a violation of your
personal rights and so is being locked
down and
we've sacrificed our civil liberties in
a dreadful manner and god only knows
what we're going to do when the next
infectious disease cycle begins because
we've
we don't know where the boundaries are
like what if we have a particularly bad
influenza
are we going to be locked down again
that the the presidents are in
and and now we have to deal with that
and that is a very terrifying issue
and to the degree that it's terrifying
and that it's a real threat
you know you're tortured by your
conscience
but you
but i don't think that it's obvious that
what you're doing is wrong
it's obvious that it's really
complicated and so
i would my response to this
is to suspend judgment for six months
for six months from now fearing as i do
the loss of civil liberties and
being wary as i am about what it means
for how we're going to handle infectious
disease in the future
where you know i'm wearing the masks
when i'm required to
so that's the best i can do with that i
have no
particular insight with regards to this
pandemic
it affected me and my family in the same
way it affects everyone else
it throws us into psychological disarray
in
all the same ways and brings up all the
same moral questions and i wish i had a
better answer but i don't so
i mean i've got the vaccine so that's
par a partial answer on my part
but i understand the position of those
who don't
want to take it and i would be unwilling
to compel them by force that's for sure
because that's not the right approach
although i would encourage people to
get the damn vaccine and get let's get
the hell over this that's
but i did that i put my body on the line
to do it
that's my decision i'm not saying it's
right it's what i decided to do
um so
give yourself a break of course you have
moral qualms and
and you should and so should all of us
but you know
i guess i would close that by saying but
let's not forget we did a pretty damn
good job of dealing with this so far i
mean it looks like a mess on the ground
but it could have been a hell of a lot
worse and i'm really amazed that it
wasn't
i know that cards haven't all fallen
into play yet
you know and who knows maybe one thing
it could do is alert us to the presence
of our real enemy
you know because we have lots of
proximal enemies and they tend to be
other people but we have a real enemy
and that tends to be infectious disease
and aids didn't quite teach us that but
and the pandemic probably wouldn't
either but
it would be a good thing to learn you
know maybe we could
aim our future selves at an increasingly
disease-free society for everyone in the
world and that's the other thing it has
to be for everyone right
because we're all the same body as it
turns out
so getting a handle on infectious
disease around the world that's an
unwarranted
good and it might have extremely
beneficial effects politically too
especially if randy thornhill is right
and
you know the worst of tyrannical
authoritarianism is driven by
concerns that arise as a consequence of
infectious disease prevalence it's a
radical hypothesis and
maybe it's true and so if we got rid of
infectious disease to the degree that we
could
if we made that public enemy number one
we might simultaneously do
be doing the best possible thing to
limit
the attractiveness of totalitarian
ideology
so well you can watch randy thornhill's
discussion with me if you want more
information
if you want more information about that
it'll be released within the next two
months
it's a killer theory so to speak so
and do you have any advice on what to do
with porn and masturbation
the less poor and the better that's my
advice but let's make that more specific
to the degree that use of porn and
masturbation is
undermining your sense of yourself and
providing you
with a dearth of motivational reasons to
get out there and engage with a real
partner
then it's definitely not in your best
interest and that's what your conscience
is telling you
you know and it's it's it's the
expedient at the expense of the
meaningful
obviously right obviously there isn't
any more obvious manifestation
of the expedient at the expense of the
meaningful
than pornography and masturbation and
that's hardly a heroic path
so maybe the less of it the better i'm
aware by the way of the statistics
showing that the
introduction of pornography into a
community doesn't raise but lowers rape
probability i think that's a separate
discussion from this but
i just want you to know i'm not ignorant
of that
you talk about beauty and the beast and
the relationship between belle and the
beast
one character i haven't heard you expand
much on
is gaston gesta himself is a beast in
his own way
yes he's the real beast can you discuss
the difference between gaston and beast
and how they relate to the real world
yes to some degree i'll do that we'll
see how much i manage it
gaston is the persona
from a union perspective whereas the
beast is the shadow he's the real thing
and in the beast there is the aggression
that needs to be integrated into the
character
into belle's world and that's masculine
that's the masculine aggression that
needs to be integrated into belle's
psyche right because you can read
beauty and the beast as a psychological
drama with beauty as the protagonist
beauty is more beautiful when she's in
relationship with the beast
and that's something to think about
because it's not you know beauty
is the heroine who's who's
uh whose first kiss resurrects her
it's a different story it's the story of
the soul the soul the necessity of the
soul to encounter
the best deal the the aggressive
the the the domineering all of that and
to incorporate it and to be able to use
it so it's the shadow and that's the
beast
gaston is a persona and the persona goes
every which way and so gasta is the
voice of the mob
and so is your persona you know because
gaston will do anything for status
anything at all except be real he has
the same problem that pinocchio is faced
with in the pinocchio story so you
remember
you may remember in the tokyo story
pinocchio's trying to shed
his strings the way that he's been
manipulated behind the scenes
right by the forces of his own psyche
being manipulated by social forces we
feel that
intensely right now it's given rise to
all this conspiratorial thinking
pinocchio is trying to move forward to
become genuine
and what are the two temptations that
are offered to him on his pathway
well the first is being an actor and i
had a hard time with that for a long
time because i thought well
i mean this is hollywood why would being
an actor be such a terrible thing but
i realized at some point something that
should have been clear to me much
earlier that
pinocchio was being offered a persona
right it's
act like you're the thing it's like the
pickup artist thing that's it
the pickup artist thing is be a great
persona
it's like well there's actually some
utility in that because no persona is
not good but
all persona is also not good and the
problem with pickup artists is that
you know they're all persona no status
and
no status doesn't mean no participation
in the power hungry
you know patriarchy it means no genuine
productive reciprocity
just the facade of that and the
signaling of that so it's a
well that's what the persona is and
that's gaston
and obviously he'll go whatever way the
crowd goes even if it means
going after his loved hypothetically
loved one's
father or even if it means going after
his soul's
father because bell is his soul and her
father is the father of us all
and so you know gestalt will sacrifice
his soul and his relationship with god
for the adulation of the mob that's
gaston
well who's the beast well obviously
gaston bell is smart enough to note that
and also to be perplexed by her
attraction to the beast
but while attraction is perplexing and
and the redeemable beast is a perplexing
entity
um that's what drove nietzsche's
cognitions on the revaluation of good
and evil at least in part and and
that that influenced jung's thinking in
a very deep manner
um
the beast is the antidote to gaston
because the beast
gaston make no mistake about it like
he's a specimen as he says himself
he's a power to be reckoned with
he's a well-developed persona but
the beast is what harbors the capacity
to withstand that
and that's why bell is attracted to him
fundamentally
he's the real thing the broken man
confronting his own shadow
so
it's a it's a brilliant piece of
animation it might be the best thing
disney ever produced uh
beauty and the beast the lyrics are the
songs are unbelievably witty it's a
it's a masterpiece that movie so bell is
the soul
the psyche the anima the beast is the
shadow
and the way to the self um
gaston is the persona
he's the pickup artist
why do we need to contemplate our own
malevolence i know it seems self-evident
no actually it doesn't it by by no means
does it seem self-evident
and i understand it for reasons such as
knowing what you're capable of so you
can be careful to avoid it but what if
you get stuck in it
how do you move forward after being
aware of it especially if you've
actually done it
i'm not speaking of criminal behavior
well you you have actually done it and
so is everybody
else so that's the first thing you
realize is that this is a
universal human problem it's also your
problem and it's your personal problem
but it's a universal human problem and
so in some sense you can let yourself
off the hook by realizing that
you know it's useful that's partly why
i think it's useful i mean that's why
i've been writing these books is to say
well here's the human universal
situation
the horror of nature the benevolence of
nature
the tyranny of social structure
the protecting sheltering nurturing
aspect of human
social structure the nobility of the
psyche
the malevolence of the adversary
all wrapped up in the dragon of chaos
that's human reality is
as i conceive it and i think it's
from that reality that religious
stories are extracted that's
really what makes them religious is that
they have those characters those
archetypal characters
as the spirits that communicate to us
and that are represented by our
religious stories and
in part by our ideologies well you need
to contemplate your own malevolence
because you
that helps you understand who you are
and who you could be
and you could be something absolutely
brutal and terrible
you could be the worst manifestation of
those who criticize the patriarchy
of of that which those who create
criticize the patriarchy accuse you of
right nothing but motivation by power
and that's certainly there especially to
the degree that you're resentful and
ungrateful etc etc
so i guess i so you need to contemplate
your own malevolence so that you
understand who you are
and that means you have to contemplate
malevolence as such because
you're not only who you are you're who
you could be for better or worse
and i actually think it's i think it's a
lot easier to start to understand who
you
could be if you were better if you
deeply understand who you could be if
you were worse
and who you might be to the degree that
you're blind to that worse
presently you know so you think oh my
god i could be that
malevolent a force for ill that's
horrible but
highly compelling and plausible given my
understanding of my own character i'm
way
deeper on the negative end than i
thought much more closely aligned with
the forces of hell than i presumed
well that's an easy that's easy to
swallow factually
right you think yeah there's evidence
for that it's not so easy to swallow
emotionally it's it's a bitter pill to
say the least
it's the black pill let's say
well what does that mean well though
that means that there's a countervailing
spirit and that's
the spirit that opposes that and that's
what you could embody
and so i don't think that you can
contemplate the good without
contemplating
the evil first even first
i don't think it has the depth it
it you're not you know they say the
beginning
that fear of god is the beginning of
wisdom it's it's something like that
necessary fear
it's like well i don't want to be a
monster okay well how much of a monster
are you well i'm as monstrous as i have
been
so that's on me conscience wise but like
i'm also
the same being that's been as monstrous
as any being throughout history
no nothing human is foreign to me let's
say
well so are you the nazi prison guard
well are you so sure you aren't
that's the real question and if you're
not so sure you aren't well are you so
sure that you shouldn't be
and i think that's an easier question i
think you're more sure than you
shouldn't be if
someone you're more sure that you
shouldn't be
if someone asked you you would say well
i shouldn't be that and perhaps have
very little
qualms on the topic qualms about the
topic
so that's what you should not be well
what's the antithesis of that well let's
say it's a good man
or more broadly speaking a good person
that's the opposite of what's malevolent
and that's a good place to start it's
like well not that
not that first and then
i can stumble up towards the light you
know insofar as i've been able to master
my darkest
self and to contemplate what that might
be
and to decide that that isn't where i'm
going no matter what
expediency be damned and i think that's
enough for tonight thanks very much for
listening and asking questions i hope
that my answers are helpful